[Music]
allison is with us in des moines iowa hi
allison how are you
hey dave i'm good um honestly i'm
nervous and also overwhelmed um my
husband and i we just started financial
peace university about two weeks ago
so we just
got done with step one uh we're working
on step two
i've done two plastectomies today
and our class is moving on to step three
but we still have some things to work on
into
as well we have about thirty thousand in
debt
uh non-mortgage debt we have three kids
and our annual
income is just over eighty eight
thousand
me being overwhelmed um
what's a reasonable time frame for the
snowball
well i just use big numbers there's a
lot of ways to look at it
um you're in ramsey plus you can jump in
there there's a snowball calculator in
there that'll help you run it out
and so you know that that's a the nerdy
detailed way to do it
but the way i look at it is 88 minus 30
is 58 you ought to be able to live on
58.
okay which means one year okay
but that's how i do it i mean it was
just a big number that's that means 2500
bucks a month
which you're just getting started so
that's probably like oh my god no
you know so i mean you haven't gotten
that far in yet you might and i'm saying
you'd have to average that you might
start out with less because you're just
getting started you just cut up the
credit cards today
and so you're not you're not in freak
mode yet when you get into freak beast
mode
and you start cutting this down cutting
your lifestyle to nothing because you're
completely obsessed with getting out of
debt you can do 30 000 on 88 in a year
that leaves you 50 it leaves you 58. but
you're gonna have
you're gonna have adjusted a whole bunch
of stuff i mean you're not going out to
eat you're not going on vacation
uh we've cleaned out all savings that's
not retirement and thrown it at the debt
we've chopped up every credit card we're
on a detailed budget
um we've sold so much stuff the kids
think they're next i mean we're
we're just you're going to be in beast
mode you're following me
yeah absolutely selling things is
actually
on my list to do i've started posting
some things already to help with that
step three yeah so what's the 30 000
what kind of debt
um well a lot of its credit cards
and then it's also truck payment
a little over 13. okay so that's half of
it
yeah and then um we just moved into a
new house
um so that's new to us it's about a
thousand
of course that's not included but
we're we still own the last place and
you know we have been talking and we're
just not sure whether we're going to
dump money in to rent it out no sell it
sell it i was waiting i was like as soon
as as soon as you're done with this he's
going to tell you to sell that house
and see that's the thing too because we
want the seller to take it off the lot
too
because we're keeping the actual
property as it was just handed over
um by his grandpa who passed away
and you know the rest is credit cards
yeah this is a trailer
yep it's a single-wide manufactured home
yeah it's a trailer yeah and so what do
you what do you got
what do you owe on it uh nothing we
actually um awesome
what will it sell oh yeah what will it
sell for
that we don't know because i mean the
inside does need some work
but we're hoping to give me a guess
10 grand i i would say maybe
10. yeah that's what i'm thinking yeah
great
now we only got to pay off 20 grand
right
and guess what that trailer is going to
be worth in five years
probably not nothing
yeah why are we keeping something that's
going down in value take your 10 grand
get out of debt
sell it now
don't fix it up it's not a fixer-upper
it's a trailer
sell it i will i will make sure to do
that because my husband's listened to
you for
a while we just never acted upon it
until recently
and we're trying to get our life back
i'm glad you are i'm so proud of you
you got a lot of balls in the air and
you really do i mean you got a lot of
you cut up your credit cards you're
selling stuff and now i sold your
trailer i mean you got a lot of stuff
going on right
you didn't know when you called yeah but
i mean this is what you do
you you know because here's the thing
it's like you're going down the
interstate
and you realize because gps goes off
that you passed the exit you missed your
turn
so now you are going 75 miles an hour in
the wrong direction
yes the first thing you do is you get
off the interstate
now you're going zero miles an hour in
the wrong direction but zero miles an
hour in the right direction
you go under the ramp under the bridge
get back up on the ramp and go back 75
miles an hour in the right direction
this is a 150 miles per hour
change this is what you're doing
so it's going to give you whiplash
absolutely yeah it's going to shock your
nervous system in a
wonderful way
if this doesn't if this doesn't feel
like a little like what
then there's something wrong with you
that's to be you talked about on another
day but
we have to wait on dr john to be here
wait till dalone's back wait a little
knees back on we'll talk about your
mental illness but you know it's it's
normal to shock the nervous system
when you say oh my gosh you know
uh i had a friend of mine who who's a
health nut and he works out all the time
and he decided that he had gotten he
kind of kicked it off and he wasn't
eating right
and he decided he's going to go all
healthy and so he's detoxing so it's
like he's got the flu yeah
he's like he's drag button around yeah
got his little lip stuck out
like he's got the flu but in you know in
a week whenever
two weeks for this to break out his diet
to change back to healthy eating
then he'll have more energy he knows
that but his body's going through this
shock yeah of change i've never heard
you give that interstate example that's
a great visual that's a great because
even the speed you're talking about like
when you're very first getting started
it's slow and then you start picking up
speed like
that's a great visual yeah but every
every mile per hour in the right
direction
is on top of the 75 miles an hour that
you were going in the wrong direction
right so it's a big change yeah it's
it's a real thing and so but it's normal
for the human system
to go oh my god for 10 years you know
i've been eating everything in sight
and all of a sudden i'm gonna change my
eating habits and of course your body's
gonna react to that
it's gonna freak out you know it's the
same thing it's the exact same thing
with your money it's the same thing with
your career
if you decide like i've never i've
always just kind of been a jerk at work
and i'm gonna go to work and smile and
actually work hard
it's gonna shock everybody they're not
gonna know how to act they're going who
are you and what have you done with that
other guy
you know it's the same thing so yeah
just shock it
you know do that do it baby get it up
get let's go
let's go you got this